[Music]  I pledged allegiance to the flag of the  once United States of America to the  Republic for which it claim to stand  [Music]  but we've become a nation under God  forsaken fools  [Music]  highly divisive liberated by lies  justified by complacency  moral high-ground it was built upon has  already begun to a room  the blood falling seeping in widening  the cast washing away the very land our  men down  [Music]  now a house divided against itself  cannot stand  what good is a folded flag or a  heart-shaped metal to a grieving family  our nation has become indifferent to  sacrifice  apathetic to the ideal spot for front  where's that they managed to pull an  ad-supported we're on our own  the time has come for wolves to lay  claim to this land  the betrayal we face gave us liver  what are you doing  [Music]  I'm a wolf  now we wage war against this plague with  fear and retribution for all  [Music]  you